life is about telling a story and
tech
now
allows the clubs
the fans
the brands
to tell a story even better than they
could before and
experience of being present somewhere
shaking the hand
and taking a picture on the pitch
although you are based in somewhere
around europe yeah
and the ability to bring people together
although you're on your own
experiencing something somebody to
something together technology has the
ability to do that
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact leap google
for startups and hippo and in media
partnership with c-tech
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
this episode is all about innovation in
sports meet amir raven the founder of
hype sports innovation
the global sports tech arena with equity
portfolio of over 250 sports tech and
web 3.0 startups
hype provides tech solutions to top 100
sports brands like bundesliga psg nba
nfl team and more amir was the founder
of mg equity investments house in 2003
he's the author of acquired charisma and
an avid soccer player he's also the
founder and ceo of media call ltd in
london which was sold in 2003. amir is
married and has four sons
hype is such an interesting organization
it looks like you're dealing right at
this intersection of sports consumers
entertainment and technology and how all
of this comes together but not just to
yourself but with a very large community
of people either from the sports side of
the tech side or the investment side so
i'm looking forward to sort of
unwrapping with you what is hype and how
how is this part of your own journey as
founder and ceo hey so maybe tell me a
little bit about you know yourself how
you got introduced into this whole
sports world and and what is sort of
this vision for hype
uh
you know
i very much believe uh
you know uh in in uh
part of the way of uh sharing the story
of hype
uh and sharing any kind of
vision
is through stories and uh
i like that
yeah recently i i remembered
uh when i was five years old
uh my grandpa in jerusalem
which was a
baitarian
took me when i was five
to see
the rival
the rivalry team apollo russia line
because that was the only game that was
that weekend and i was so persistent to
see something uh as i liked football and
my father couldn't care less
uh on on to sports and i remember him
taking me to the game and come me coming
to the
the pitch as you know through the stairs
seeing the grass
and really feeling it in my
guts
this feeling
and i have it with me uh he then told me
that i brought a spare of shoes in case
one of the players will be wounded and i
i will need to jump into the game and
play
i was five the game was a poor jerusalem
versus apollo typha it was he said the
most boring game in the world
but for me it was an unforgettable
experience now 40 years later i'm taking
my son
to germany to the bundesliga to see
after kern versus byron munich
in cologne
and my son is in my hand
we had an accelerator for sportstech
there
and i'm looking around and saying bloody
hell uh
not much has changed
since i was a kid and you have a big
screen but not a lot more has changed
you think about it
sure
so
later on together
with the german partner uh bernd waller
which used to be the cmo of adidas
global adidas
uh
we developed ip's fault innovation to
the next stage and then we have nine
nine we had nine accelerators of sports
tech around the world including
one in uh nyu
uh australia with the queensland
university in london many many others
and so i just want to revisit that that
point you're mentioning that you're
you're seeing the stifling perhaps or
stifled innovation in in such a
meaningful part
and and you're saying it doesn't align
you know the world is shifting to we
have technology we have things happening
why is my experience as a consumer or
for my kid now the same as it was for me
when i was you know his age 40 years ago
but still at that moment how you sort of
what is the thesis that you build around
the potential for innovation and
technology to be integrated into sports
what what is sort of your your role in
that
you know in that stage uh i saw that
there is a gap there is an opportunity
you know
that there is a lot of stuff around
sports around me and i couldn't ex sorry
a lot of innovation around me and i
couldn't really explain why there is not
enough innovation in sports yet later on
i started really analyzing it i
understand why the big teams were i
would say
fat and happy and uh
not needing to
innovate now of course with the new
generation z generation and the
streaming and the esports around them
they have to
innovate in order to get hold of the the
next generation but by back then
returning five six years ago
uh it was
only it in its early stages and as a i
would say as an entrepreneur in the
wrong side of the 50s i thought maybe
it's about time i do something i really
really love
which
my passions always always were sports
and innovation you know as an
entrepreneur i sold my business in 2003
i lived in london for 10 years
sold it and then started investing in a
small investment house full mg equity
partners but it wasn't really there i
was looking you know to come back to my
entrepreneurial role to create something
to make an impact
to drive something forward and
with hype and that's what we're doing
and you rightly said in the beginning
what is actually hype is doing because
it looks a little bit i would say
all over the place
what we found is that in order to help
entrepreneurs and startups and invest in
them later on
we need to have also the other side we
need to have the brands as partner
so we started
working and supporting the brand the
clubs the federations
like the golden state warriors like the
paris saint-germain like
a fiba
uh swiss timing uh wilson sports and
many many others
where globally we can work with them
enable them to
take use the best innovations
uh and on the other hand
once we have them as customers we can
bring them the best technologies and the
best sellers
got it and so as you're positioning sort
of building through this accelerator
investment platform the brand
what is the messaging what is the the
platform that that brings everybody
together that that allows for this
innovation to actually take place
i think that
what
you know the vision that we had and i
think i think it's still very much a
um
you know very very strong still is to
impact people's lives
through the power of sports and
innovation and
if you think about it if you're an
entrepreneur lives in uh i know san
diego or in
torino or in belgium
the biggest i would say elder or the
biggest jump for you to really break
through
will be
to get a pilot or commercial deal with a
tough tier club
then
it will be much easier to get the
investors and it all will unfold
properly in place so that's what we do
basic and what we felt is that
as the platform that is global
uh
originally with all the nine
accelerators globally but then with the
with the pandemic and we started the gv8
global virtual accelerator we shut down
all the
physical accelerators in a day and we
created this global platform which to be
honest
is much more effective of course i see
my kids more which is better and and
you know much better from my wife's
perspective as well but in in as a whole
we've learned to work as a global
community
with mentors we have about 100 mentors
from all over the world we have
investors we have uh brands and
of course startups we see about 1500
startups a year so
that's created the platform which really
brings value to the different
stakeholders and
continue to grow and we believe that
through this platform because sports is
so powerful uh you can really impact if
you have this global and every side of
the
the platform campaign that can can
engage and can give value to the other
can you give me some examples of where
innovation really is taking place in the
sports world just for people who may not
necessarily be experiencing in the
day-to-day what are some things that
you're excited about as innovation is
unfolding in sports
so when i'm speaking to people like uh
if i'm meeting somebody which is not
into uh specifically sports or sports
tech and he he hears faulty thing ah so
you do this garbage uh innovation uh on
the hands stuff that people can
so sports is more than that yeah uh to
give you an idea uh we're doing this
weekend we have a game between roma
and
tottenham hotspur
you know two of the biggest european the
south you know i would say top 10
european clubs
coming to israel to haifa to sami
official where we create the high tech
cup
which is basically it's a competition
it's a cup around innovation where since
we are not part of teachers we have we
don't have the restrictions of the
leagues and ufo
we can put any innovation with all
and
if you're asking
which are the innovations that we will
be the stars of the show so for example
you will be able to see
the pawn
from the angle of the player imagine
you know we have hurricane from england
coming if he's shooting a penalty you
can see the game the the penalty from
his angle
you can see it from the goalkeeper we
have a camera on the referee
here
we have uh nft
and metaverse engagement to the fans
globally so they can engage they can
talk to each other they have
an additional
content which they wouldn't have
through their regular boat broadcasting
which is in parallel
so what are ways in which nft and the
metaverse are going to impact
engagements of fans if i'm a fan of a
sports team how is how is this new
virtual engagement going to increase my
presence or my engagement with this team
or player that i love yeah i would say
that uh it's yet to be
clear
all day i would say the the full impact
like any kind of new
technology and the web 3 or the web 2.5
how this will impact sports and how this
will impact the you know not only sports
uh all the other things but since
blockchain is a very
real
uh i would say
technology which brings a lot of unique
values i think
this is the basic that will
will be the fuel
a for for
all the web 3 to continue to grow and to
this
a layer of
a monetization new monetization platform
that was not there before to the cloud
the brand of the federations if you look
at the nba top shots yeah which is
trading in you know hundreds of million
uh uh dollars and uh you know and you
look at the the number of investment now
being done in nfc nft from 2020 to 2021
jumped in 210 times the
overall revenue of transactions so it's
crazy numbers
again the
not all of them are haves real substance
behind it but when you have a
combination of a real technologies
blockchain and
a rail monetization new monetization
tool which need to be refined and there
will be some corrections and you know
maybe most of the nfts now are not going
to be here for for forever or long time
but still
the this as a fan coming back to your
question
as a fan if you hold a uh
a ticket
to the final in wembley if you're uh i
don't know an english fan
of some of the teams and you have it as
an nft
and this nft also gives you credit uh or
access to a shop later on when you can
get something or you can get access to
another game
with a discount
or you can have this as a memorabilia
that's something that probably people
will use
uh
you know uh we are doing like uh now a
uh scarves where have some kind of nfc
chip into them so you can
really get into a game it allows you
just to walk in it allows you access to
additional
content which
nobody else has if you have this stuff
so
there is now the metaverse of course you
can engage and meet friends and play
games and watch the game there in the
meta verse yeah
uh so
we and you know the young generation as
being used to living in the games and
you know metaverse to some extent you
know is another
form of game
you can just see that there is a
potential here to to create something
bigger hype you know
we would like to continue help driving
drive this industry forward
help be a
force for good so to look at regulation
to look at what we can do to
make this you know to help to structure
things in a better manner
and uh
alongside that
continue to be their business we are
for-profit organization we have a
portfolio now of about
a hundred sorry 250 startups we have
equity in
so to continue to build our equity
and um and have some fun all the way if
possible so so this equity is primarily
from the accelerator that you bring in
those startups and you work with them
and you and you create that platform for
them right
yes
and started actually
when i was an entrepreneur
about 27 years old how old are you
okay your age
i remember after starting my own company
in london
after i did the
i had four pilots with with the fourth
brand which was the bank of scotland
i got a no after a pilot of three months
and i remember
i was i i i felt it's the end of the
world and i had nobody to talk to it was
97.
wow there was very little internet if at
all i don't think wyant was around by
then
uh to speak to somebody you need to call
into it cost a fortune i had very few
people in london i knew
and i was really on my own
i remember walking on london bridge and
walking and looking down literally
and uh
today and and one of the
you know
one of the reasons we created this
startup and founders platform is to
enable them
not to be on the road
to enable them to have fun to have other
founders they can talk to to have
mentors
in different topics
you know mentor can save you
thousands you know we didn't have
youtube there where we can just log in
how do i penetrate the uk how do i close
a deal how and you see everything
so
this was behind i would say some of some
of it i could see only in hindsight but
when i look back i think the feeling of
being on your own
is something that i would say has a very
strong impact
no i can see you're you're you're taking
your own experience and this is a
meaningful part of why you're creating
this community right it's not just an
investment arm it's not just a
you know a
you know a mitigator between parties
you're you really do value working with
the founders and creating some some
community for them to
to get assistance from and help from
right
absolutely
so if you're looking at you know the
future of of sports and innovation and
tech
what are some of some things that
you know you're particularly excited
about as an entrepreneur yourself so
you're seeing all these amazing
companies you were talking about the you
know the different point of views and
the metabolisms etc
are there other other things that are
non-trivial that
maybe we can get excited for and how
sports are going to be intertwined with
our lives maybe in a few years down the
line
i think that uh
you know looking at your question i
think
it's it's difficult to predict how
things will shape up especially with the
young generation my kids which you know
their
you know their uh
uh way they see uh and live there
i would say through gaming and through
the different new platforms they have
i do know that sports
has a very special power to connect
people
and have a very special special power to
do good
um
i want to see sports
more involved in that i know that for
example if you think about the potential
of metaverse it remains seeing how the
i would say regulations will work safety
etcetera but
in terms of equal
opportunities allowing people from
everywhere in the world to participate
in an experience and to be part of this
uh not everybody can fly and see the
champions league final
right
uh
allowing people to to experience
allowing people to communicate
allowing you know reducing a mission by
you know less people flying
there are a lot of
good things that can happen and
as you know coming back to the beginning
of the session life is about telling a
story
sure and
sp
now
allows the clubs
the fans
the
uh
the the brands to tell a story even
better than they could before and the
experience of being present somewhere
shaking the hand
and taking a picture on the pitch
although you are based in somewhere
around europe yeah
and the ability to bring people together
although you're on your own
with an empty uh fridge
and not nobody is home but
experiencing something somebody to
something together
technology has the ability to do that
whether
we
will be able to every all of us will be
able to use that to do better to do good
to put people together
this is for us to to prove this is for
us to uh to execute
thank you
amazing this is wonderful
uh
really appreciate your your time and and
the stories and i can see how this all
ties back to your own experience as an
entrepreneur in it so i love it and i
look forward to continue seeing the
awesome work that you're doing with hype
and i personally get excited about how i
will be integrating into the sports
world myself and not just as a as a
player but it's a consumer so thank you
very very much
pleasure to be here michelle and i i see
the um the work you're doing around
spreading goodness around the world so
good luck with that and well done thank
you very very much
[Music]